Die bayerischen Alpen
sind ein Winterreiseziel
für Urlauber jeden Alters.
Auf zahlreichen Wegen und Loipen
können Ski-Langläufer und Wanderer
Sport und Naturerlebnis verbinden.
Der kleine Ort Ruhpolding
liegt nahe der österreichischen Grenze
und bietet typisch süddeutsche
Architektur und Atmosphäre.
Rund 6.300 Menschen leben hier
an den Ausläufern der Alpen.
Vor allem im Winter
übersteigt die Zahl der Touristen
deutlich die der Einwohner.
Das liegt zum einen
am Biathlon-Weltcup,
der hier jedes Jahr ausgetragen wird.
Zudem finden Athleten
wie Skicross-Profi Thomas Fischer
hier gute Trainingsmöglichkeiten.
Es heißt, Bilder sagen mehr
als tausend Worte,
und des trifft’s eigentlich genau gut,
also ...
Hinter uns wären
eigentlich Seen im Sommer.
Die sind jetzt
Gott sei Dank verschneit.
Die … die Pisten hier sind …
sind sensationell.
Man kann Hunderte von
Kilometer[n] hier laufen,
und wenn man Glück hat, trifft man
sogar auch an … an Profi-Sportler.
Aber sogar Amateure haben hier
die einzigartige Gelegenheit,
wie Profis zu trainieren –
natürlich mit ausgebildeten Trainern.
Dies ist das Biathlon-Trainingsgelände,
das der ehemalige Biathlet
Fritz Fischer leitet.
Also, wichtig ist, wenn’s ihr
am Schießstand herkommts,
dass einfach der Sicherheitsbereich
ganz großgeschrieben wird.
Net mit der Waffe umeinandspielen,
sondern die Waffe liegt immer do.
„Sicherheit zuerst“
lautet hier das Motto.
Sie machen Lauftechnik,
sie üben die Skating-Technik.
Und wenn ma
nach a Stunde fertig sind,
dann hat jeder mal die Chance,
hier zu schießen
und anschließend mit einem kleinen
Wettkampf auch mal zu erleben,
wie so ein Sportler
hier in dieser Kulisse
mehr oder weniger auch
bei so am schönen Wetter
jetzt mal a bissl
Sport machen kann.
Fritz Fischer hat 1992 bei den
Olympischen Winterspielen in Frankreich
eine Goldmedaille
für Deutschland geholt.
Vom aktiven Wettkampfsport
hat er sich zurückgezogen.
Heute arbeitet er als Trainer
in der eigenen Anlage.
Sein Augenmerk liegt auf den Waffen.
Das ist jetzt eine Kleinkaliber-Waffe –
5,6 Millimeter.
Das ist die Munition,
sieht man hier,
die ist dann vorne
in den Magazinen drin,
jeweils fünf Schuss.
Und des Thema ist des …
der Sicherheitsbereich ist hier sehr,
sehr großgeschrieben bei dem,
bei dem Biathlon-Erleben.
Weil man sagt, das ist eine scharfe …
eine scharfe Waffe
und man muss
immer so weit hier vorne sein,
damit diese Mündung vorne
über dieser Kante steht.
Die Teilnehmergruppe
ist bunt gemischt –
von Studenten
bis zu Handwerkern,
von ehemaligen Profisportlern
bis zu Geschäftsleuten.
Sie alle wollen vor allem eins:
Der Spaß steht im Vordergrund.
Ja, ist cool –
bis auf das Schießen halt.
Drei, zwei, eins – Start!
Und dann geht es richtig los!
Die Langläufer müssen
eine komplette Runde laufen,
bevor es ans Schießen geht.
Jeder Schütze wird von einem
professionellen Trainer begleitet,
der darauf achtet,
dass alle Regeln eingehalten werden.
Und genau wie beim echten Biathlon
gibt es Strafen fürs Danebenschießen –
in diesem Fall Kniebeugen.
Nur nacheinander
dürfen die Teilnehmer loslegen.
Jeder muss erst seine
gesamte Runde beendet haben,
bevor der Nächste starten kann.
Zwei Stunden Training
mit voller Ausrüstung
kosten 149 Euro pro Person.
Am Ende des Tages
gibt es noch eine Erfrischung
in einer der vielen
Après-Ski-Hütten.
Diese Hütten sind meistens
im traditionellen Blockhaus-Stil erbaut
und liegen im ganzen Tal verstreut.
Geöffnet sind sie
während der gesamten Saison.
Hier lässt es sich nach einem harten
Biathlon-Training gut entspannen.
Anstrengend ein wenig,
aber es hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht.
Wir haben zumindest
nicht alles daneben geschossen.
Also, wir haben auch
ab und zu getroffen.
Ja, hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht.
Die Berge, die Pisten, der Sport
und das kalte Wetter
machen einen Winterurlaub
in Ruhpolding unvergesslich.